should we go to the moon or should we go
to Mars we should go to both but I guess
the real question is where do we go next
what's the next step and I think this
goes back to the orbital perspective as
well I think the orbital perspective you
know the part of the ordinal perspective
that talks about long-term planning you
know let's look 20 30 40 50 years down
the road and see what affects our
decisions that we make today will take
us you know what trajectory will not put
us on where will that get us in that
timeframe and so if we go to Mars first
which we can do I say it was probably be
10 to 15 years from the time we make a
decision to go to Mars we could probably
get to Mars and but by making a decision
that means we've allocated the necessary
funding etc etc but another path to Mars
would be to go to the moon first and by
going to the moon first and and what I
mean by that is by establishing a
transfer transportation infrastructure
between the earth and the moon and a
permanent human presence on the moon so
we have routine travel between Earth and
its nearest neighbor by doing that that
would open up the hole in the entire
solar system that enables us to use the
resources that are on the moon it
enables us to launch in a much lower
gravity field than earth it opens up
tremendous benefits to the entire
population of the earth by making use of
our nearest neighbor there's energy on
the moon there's scientific discoveries
on the moon the list goes on and on all
the benefits to earth that the moon
provides and so not only would we get
those benefits not only would we be able
to have this traffic infrastructure -
for routine travel to the earth on the
moon but we'd open up the rest of the
solar system including Mars so to me
from a long-term point of view it makes
sense to have the next step being to
return to the moon this time to stay
you